the perfect picnic breakfast my ultimate
Scotch eggs with a twist I go fishing a
lot and Scotch eggs are the perfect
all-in-one mini picnic breakfast first
thing get your eggs cooked bring the
water up the ball onto the spoon and
lower them into the water that way they
don't hit the water and crack four and
half minutes that will keep the center
nice it's slightly runny now ground
sausage meat I'm gonna make mine a
little bit spicier or crumble in black
pudding that helps to season Scotch eggs
inside a little touch of salt and pepper
and then just to make it a little bit of
sweeter and a lot easier for the kids to
eat some grated apple combined that
blend in the apple and the black pudding
eggs once they're cooked drain them and
then run them under cold water cracking
and cooling the eggs quickly will
prevent the yolks turning gray tap them
on the side of the pan put them back
into the water and what happens the
water seeps underneath the shell see the
Shelf come off so much easier eggs still
slightly soft and center on that little
bit of richness with the yolk next you
need to get yourself organized with a
mini assembly-line seasoned flour a
little egg wash and bread crumbs
take your mince Gopal sighs spread the
pate manipulate with your thumb and then
sit your egg in there and spread the
sausage over the egg and you just seal
that over it's really important to keep
that nice even coating of sausage meat
around the egg you don't want it too
thick otherwise it gets too dense and
it's unappetizing give them a light
dusting and the seasoned flour you don't
put the flour on the egg wash won't
stick now if you don't put the egg wash
on the breadcrumbs won't stick into yolk
roll it round shake off any excess egg
wash roll it into your breadcrumbs you
can use this same three-stage method to
bread crumb anything you'd like from
chicken GU Jones and fish Phillips to
FINA schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs Japanese
white bread crumb so no crust you can
experiment by adding flavors to your
breadcrumbs like Parmesan herbs or
citrus zest always like to push the
actual bread crumbs into the sauce meat
so it gets that really nice golden brown
and stops any of the outside burning
once bread crumbs low the eggs carefully
into a four centimeter deep bath of hot
vegetable oil for 10 to 12 minutes do
you exactly cooked soft and running the
center so the objective is just to cook
the sausage Lee and the black pudding
let's brighten it got angry Nate there's
something so magical about a scotch egg
on a picnic because it's like this
little mini breakfast useful bring them
onto the paper roll them around just to
get off any excess oil and then to
transport them some greaseproof paper
mat for me is the perfect start to the
fishing trip there's no wonder I never
catch any fish because I'm always too
busy eating my Scotch eggs
my ultimate black pudding lace Scotch
eggs and irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast
[Music]